Donald Trump had a completely whacked out
speech at the rally in the conservative stronghold
of Colorado Springs.
Now it's a story for another day.
Colorado Springs.
Colorado is a
fascinating conservative place.
Fascinatingly scary.
I guess I should add, but I do want to highlight
a moment from this completely absurd speech
and focus in on Donald Trump actually bragging
that his followers are completely cult-like
and divorced from any critical thinking whatsoever
that would even conceivably allow them to
say maybe Trump did something wrong and we
should hold them accountable.
Just like a cult leader and the more I watch
interviews with Trump supporters, I'm reminded
more and more of the book road to Jonestown
by Jeff Gwyn that I read.
It's about cult leader Jim Jones.
Drink the Koolaid originates from Jim Jones
and I recommend the book to you.
It's an aside, but Trump is to reminding me
more and more of Jim Jones followers and more
and more the term cult is actually being used
to describe the supporters of Donald Trump
and Trump is bragging about this.
Let's take a look at the clip.
A visibly sweaty and orange.
Donald Trump bragging about his cultist followers.
Thank you.
CNN went up to I a woman.
What does it take for you to leave the president?
I'm not leaving him.
There were 10 women and the one woman beautiful
to like incredible women and they had their
bandanas.
I had had struck and stupid CNN.
They go up, what does it take for you?
And then he got look, he said one time that
his people are so good they'd stay with them.
They shot somebody in the middle of fifth
Avenue to remember shot somebody.
They actually, this is actually an answer,
something to the effect.
Would you say every shot somebody in the middle
of fifth Avenue and the woman looks out the
pans, why he shot him?
So Donald Trump, there was ridiculing a question
that is essentially a defease ability test.
It's what would it take for you to change
your mind about Donald Trump?
This is a really great question that I've
talked about before and it can be very easily
used to determine whether someone is actually
thinking critically and using facts to come
to a conclusion or are they first coming to
their conclusion and then just post facto
interpreting the facts to fit that preexisting
notion that they have.
If there is nothing a president could do to
make you re-examine your support for them,
you are not operating in the world of facts
and critical thinking.
If someone came to me and said, David, what
would it take for you to support Donald Trump?
I could very clearly tell you, listen, if
Trump came around on climate and said he was
wrong all along and he's committing to fight
climate change, if he came around on trade,
if he stopped using the presidency to funnel
money into his own pockets, if he apologize
for all the disgusting behavior, if you fix
this, fix this tax plan.
It's a long list, but I would consider saying
Trump might be better than some of these Democrats
that are running.
I'm at least trying to operate in the world
of thinking critically and behaving rationally.
So Donald Trump is not only criticizing CNN
in the clip for asking that a feasibility
question, he's actually bragging about how
his supporters are essentially cult followers.
They've decided to support Trump and will
after the fact rationalize anything Donald
Trump says and does.
It might sound like they're applying some
critical thinking when Trump says, well, they'd
keep supporting me if I shot someone, depending
on why I shot someone.
But that entire discussion has already rationalized
a president even talking about shooting people
on fifth Avenue and not losing support and
not having his followers abandoned him.
So this clip should serve as a reminder to
us that given the cult like nature of Donald
Trump's followers, convincing them to change
their minds about who they're going to vote
for in November is so utterly and obviously
few tile.
It is not a strategy for winning the election.
What we have to do is mobilize people who
don't have to be convinced, who aren't part
of the cult and Trump bragging about it is
just an additional reminder of that Trump
bragging that his followers are essentially
cultists.
Let's now get to some other clips from some
of Donald Trump's recent rallies.